how did you guys feel about like the ufo
machines or like what like the prize
machines here in japan aki's [ __ ]
amazing at it and i
don't know how she because what what
really surprised me is that
most in most like in everywhere else
it's kind of like a look kind of like
like one based
but in here i see people who are just
really good at these machines
and they can actually turn it into a
profit because then they just sell the
figures
or whatever you get or buy that's a huge
industry as well yeah yeah
that's a big deal like a lot of the
stores in akihabara are selling crane
game stuff yeah how did they get
i just don't understand how people can
get good at that because aki's
every time we go to an arcade aki always
is less like [ __ ] the rhythm games
i'm just gonna go to the korean games to
just get random [ __ ] but every time i
try it and she's standing next to me
she's always like oh no you should move
that more to the right
wait how do you know that i was just
[ __ ] going for it but
there's like a whole like secret thing
where it's like yeah you have to aim it
slightly to the left so that it drags
the
plushie closer to the hole i'm just
gonna do that how do you figure that
[ __ ] out i just want to go beep beep and
pick up
like i don't want to i don't want to
think about this i want to just play it
i guess you have to if you want to like
not spend as much money but if i really
really want the thing in the crane i'll
just go to the shop next door that
probably is selling it used for like 800
yen which is way cheaper than it would
be yeah every time you go to an arcade
in akihabara there's always the store
next to it is
the exact thing you're trying to gamble
for but in japan if you mess up enough
and you put enough money in the machine
the staff will come over and be like
uh hey you you wanna you're in hell we
feel we feel kind of bad you've spent
like
how many thousands of years yeah which
is why like when i have friends who are
doing it who are [ __ ] up loads and
they put like 20 bucks i'm like
do i put like 10 more bucks and then
i'll call the staff over yeah
and if you do that normally they'll
place it they'll pick it up
literally put it on the box yeah and
just require you to like tap it
yeah like they'll pretty much set it up
for you baby modes
activated it's literally baby mode so
that pro tip if you come to japan
use your gaijin
in america no i haven't actually i've
seen them but i've always been scared to
try them i guess because you can set the
crane game to how difficult you want it
yeah
and just knowing how like a lot of at
least american
crane games that i've played i mean how
they
there might as well not be it's
basically just a slot machine with the
claw attached
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah
yeah i'd rather put my money into this
actual slot machine than a crane game
which i would not rather do anyway yeah
yeah
but no there's like a lot of different
games that you just don't see anywhere
else
in arcades like i don't know why there's
always there's always a fake go
like section that's it's it's not just
one machine
there's an entire round there's a row of
fake go machines in every [ __ ] arcade
i
swear to god and those machines have you
played on those machines [ __ ]
expensive what what what is it i've
never played the game
the cards right yeah it's it's so
they're expensive because you can print
out physical cards
of the waifus that you get in fake oh yo
for real yeah
oh you don't know that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i'm surprised oh
[ __ ] no cause you'll be broke don't
don't know so no be one of my best
friends here um he
is like a super heavy like fake go
player i mean he used to be
aka he has no money yeah aka he's broke
right so i don't need to give faye
anymore
don't tell me this don't tell me but he
wouldn't but from what i saw because i
went to an arcade with him and he was
like oh
can i just go onto the fake go machines
i'm like yeah actually because i've
always wanted to know what they were
i've always
walked past them and yeah it's like it's
like a double screen it's like a giant
ds essentially where the bottom screen
is like a touch screen
and you have these packet of cards and
you can essentially use cards to summon
fake characters that's so cool
oh my god you've shown me this and if
you like win like
any it's like you use the fake
characters to like beat like a certain
quest it's kind of like dragon quest
with fake characters
and if you beat a certain quest and
depending on how you beat it
then you can unlock different waifus and
you can actually print out the waifus
from the machine oh
is already expensive enough but of
course they take money to like actually
print out the cards
so it's just like so much money for the
fake franchise right now and i know
after today you're going to go to you're
just going to see me in a week and just
go like guys i've sunk way too much
money and she's going to come in with
like a deck
like why why why why did you say you
never went on it considering you made
that whole
gotcha video i mean like because it
because of quarantine like yeah like
it was current scene that started my
process for the gacha video so
i haven't actually been to an arcade
since quarantine started so i've just
been playing fago
and so i know what we're doing after
this episode we're going to an arcade
that has a fake go machine
like skylanders but for questionable
adults
that's what it sounds like you can like
summon the cards oh okay i mean
i mean to be fair it's pretty [ __ ] i
mean that's that's basically gotcha
games
okay yeah yeah exactly i mean you're
just you're just collecting pngs or
cards or whatever literal png's printed
out
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah wait so you're
telling me that we're not just
collecting pngs
but they're physical and printed out bro
laminated cards
once a png always appears man
you know the coolest game i ever saw in
an arcade here was you know typing of
the dead it's actually an arcade machine
are you serious
yeah it's in akihabara it's on like the
one of the sega buildings
they have like four sega buildings yeah
one of them one of them
the typing of the dead mod they actually
have a typing of the dead so it's a
house that does but you
type yeah so what there's like a
keyboard it's a keyboard two keyboards
right actually oh that's so good
it's so [ __ ] cool you get a picture
of it yeah that's so cool i remember
being next to the game where you tipped
the table
what an arcade game in japan where all
you do
is like you have to tip this table as
hard as possible you know you know you
know in like american arcades they have
the punching machines
yeah it's that but instead of punching
something you just slip the tape yeah
yeah you flip it as hard as you can on
the screen right now there'll be a
reference
but yeah it's really [ __ ] cool yeah
it's very fun it's like but it's kind of
expensive because you get one flip
yeah and then you better make that flip
count
that sounds [ __ ] amazing yeah it's
good it's only in japan only in japan
where else can you flip a table in real
life and just get away with it yeah
you'll have to clean up the mess
not only get away with it but be
rewarded
well done you got a high score in your
like home countries did you ever have
like these
arcades at home where they would they
would like have this one japanese arcade
machine
and that like everyone would be honest
in in wales they didn't but in london
they did yeah in london there's a few i
remember there was one arcade machine
called like i think it was bishibashi
i love that game yeah yeah but like in
london it was like a really really
old like okay it was beating up and in
here like i didn't realize there was
like
new iterated versions of it right right
yeah bishibashi is a lot of fun it's
just basically like mario party you want
to crash
with only one mechanic yeah you have to
press your button in certain ways but
it's one button i mean
ishibashi means to hit oh yeah yeah
that's why because there's some
some games you just like yeah like i'm
spamming it those games
it's a fun game you should play it if
you have a comment yeah it's super fun
yeah basically like i feel like
one of some of the one of the weeb
experiences go to akihabara but i feel
like you'd be missing half that by not
going to an arcade as well
yeah and that's the good thing about
japanese arcades right is that you don't
have to go to occupy harborough to
experience
no no you don't literally everywhere
yeah it's definitely like a
different gaming experience from normal
gaming in a way that like
is hard to quantify the value of i guess
because as a gamer
right i love i love i love
spending 10 hours a day playing video
games but like i i can't spend more than
like four hours in an arcade in japan
yeah it's hard yeah it depends on the
game for me yeah
i mean i i think nowadays it's hot as
well yeah
oh it's so funny if you're on the floor
they smoke like because there's always
one floor where you're allowed to smoke
yeah yeah oh my god that floor reeks oh
yeah yeah i mean
i i feel like nowadays i probably have a
little bit of an easier time because
i've
kind of diversified my rhythm bring
headphones bring headphones
oh yeah bring headphones bring your own
headphones you need an uh an aux cord
basically yeah yeah but if you don't
then you're gonna try and play a rhythm
game while you're hearing 50 other
yeah yeah yeah at the same time i think
that's why it's so hard for me to sit
down most times before for like
months i didn't use headphones i
couldn't get into it but when i put
headphones on
i just do like maybe like an hour but i
can't sit there
it feels so good because i remember the
first time i tried the piano machine and
i didn't have headphones and i'm just
like i can't even hear the music
so i'm just i'm just playing press the
color yeah you know what i mean like
like
i'm i'm it's not it's there's no rhythm
to this game i'm just smashing
what i see on screen yeah yeah like with
headphones i'm like oh this
this feels good
i feel like a [ __ ] master at playing
piano and i'm here i'm just like
like smashing something pretty colors